I would pay 179 after 50 years of case
study and everyone's [__] 2 000 years
old because this planet of course you
take that long and [__] that math
doesn't add up by the way yeah after 50
years everyone
[Music]
what are you guys thoughts on
genetically modified foods and stuff oh
wonderful delicious my favorite it
tastes amazing have you ever had that
grape that you eat and it tastes like
cotton candy GMO baby it's like 75 it's
[__] crazy everyone this super shiny
crispy apples have you had a Sumo
Tangerine those are crazy those are I
can't wait till they invent more fruits
with GMO I had like a a more GMOs a plum
flavored apple one time oh what's the
point of having these fruits that taste
like other fruits what's the point of
having what's the point of having
Doritos that tastes like nachos just get
nachos right yeah yeah [__] [__]
have you had an apple that tastes like
watermelon oh my god
well that can understand because it
takes up my space well it's also it's
not as hard to get a chili dog but
they're like chili dog flavored Doritos
it's like
uh yeah could just buy a chili dog right
now but I think I'm gonna try this
scope is so wide it's like anything from
a [__] freakishly made star-shaped
banana to like a regular banana
fun
so imagine peeling that thing how about
a genetically engineered house plant
that cleans air as efficiently as 30
plants yes
house plant that cleans air like 30
plants the equivalent of having 30
plants in one plant so it's like a air
purifier imagine having 30 of those
places I love it wow wow quality bear is
good it's like an oxygen poisoning
actually it's too rich your house
becomes a clean
I wonder how they do that this is a
paris-based startup they made um this
house plant it's clean the air within
your home it builds off of the natural
purifying properties that house plants
already have so while it also you know
you know there's a nice little
decoration it's actually giving you way
more utility than your normal house
plant does it have Bluetooth Paris needs
that [__] have you ever been there is
stank it sucks pears is dirty did it
stink too it's a little bit some areas
it's beautiful but it's dirty
what kind of stink are we talking man
like Smog and [__] dirty bodies and
dirty bodies a dirty bodies we can't say
that much man we're like in Los Angeles
is that because of 20 but we got Skid
Row stench that's something else right
but I think the difference is we have
um dry air in La yeah so it's not as bad
Oh no you're right you're right okay if
you go in there in the summer it's human
that's bacteria and no one uses AC I'm
like it's hot
your car we go into all these Ubers they
[__] you could it just smells like
cigarettes it just smells like an
Eastern European dad you're gonna be
like just Bo cigarettes and cologne so
it is true about the French people say
they smell bad oh not like the people
perpetuating like the taxis the taxis ah
like it's pretty rough yeah I think in
Europe generally people will you'll just
smell more Bo like people are less like
freaked out about their own Bo out there
that's true maybe we're just stuck up in
a winter no one stinks
that's so lovable though
this house plant though like
um the intention was to genetically
modify it so that it could purify air
like that's literally their intention
they don't want it to grow faster they
don't want it to be any more resistant
to pesticides than normal plants they
just want it to be better for your air
quality in your home how do they test
that
oh my God that is um
I could breathe better
we're just gonna we're just gonna assume
that this is true yeah that's horrible
because like it's really hard to test I
think about this air purifier and I
think about how it uses a machine to
actually pull air in and push it out so
like there's actual movement I don't
think a plant's gonna be like flapping
air around in order to constantly suck
in new air to purify it right I'm
curious how the plants make oxygen
because I learned it in school but I
still don't see any air air coming out
of those leaves we have no proof because
you don't see it happening doesn't mean
it's not happening yeah yeah but like I
want to measure it with an air barometer
yeah you're right it's not going to suck
up the dust well it's not it takes
carbon dioxide it makes it actually
execute that's a regular plant this is
talking about air purifying oh that's
what that is air purifying yeah it's not
saying it produces 30 more or 30 times
more oxygen yeah yeah
you're purifying oh what I thought
plants don't purify air but they just
make oxygen yeah well you thought wrong
[__] oh I didn't [__] know they
don't do it that well but this one does
it 30 times don't you understand so it's
like just as good as like an air
purifier maybe I don't even think it's
close to being as good as air purifier I
don't think that's what I'm saying like
how's it it's not like we still need 30
of these plants air purifiers don't mean
no they just clean the dust in the air
you're not getting plants for your home
because you need more oxygen in your
house
it's true you need more style yeah
that's true are you saying this thing's
a meme you think it's a marketing Point
yeah I think it's a little bit of a meme
how expensive what's the price point
purchasing the concept you know take any
plant Times by 30. yeah that's too much
that's too much well they took NASA
technology to develop this [__] so like
they're definitely including that in
like the way so then they don't need
they could just have one of those in
their space helmet you can [__]
breathe infinitely yeah less questions
we'll just stamp these things on it and
then it'll be make more sense I also
think about like an air purifier and
it's got like a filter in it right and
then like sucks in the air and then like
if there's dirt or dust or whatever or
pollen or whatever the [__] it'll get
like trapped in that filter as it pushes
air out right but I don't again same
thing I don't see a plant like sucking
dust from the air and like so it's a
filter that looks like a plant
that's
all that's a really good idea damn it is
it's like cell phone towers that
obviously are cell phone towers but they
look like trees and they look dead on
like trees I always get so tricked now
they're Street lamps dude but I
appreciate it you know what I mean I'm
like there's a funny uh like
almost like a uh it doesn't a paradox
because here you have this product
that's for people that are that don't
let's say they don't want to purifier
because they want natural solutions yet
they're not going to buy something from
a GMO creating company
so it's like you're you're kind of
zoning in on your audience and then
you're alienating them in the same pitch
so this is the plant
okay so how much do you think this costs
I'm so surprised
does it come with the pot huh does it
come with a pot
because if it does it's the prices maybe
like 65 that's gonna be like 85. what if
the real purifier is just a pot that's
what I'm saying for the plant what's the
price how many monies okay I say 200
Euros oh why are we in Euros because
it's French yeah that's true I'll tell
you what if I forget to water this thing
it's still gonna work
you put water in there this guy hates
plants I didn't know that you didn't
know you put water in those things no oh
no yours never worked I thought those
were just humidifiers I never knew air
purifiers you had water you don't okay I
was I was making sarcastic comment on
the plane
I don't know new technology so we're
really clear that this thing is not it's
supposed to be a purifier and not just
making 30 times more oxygen fighting air
pollution yeah in your home I think
we're missing something yeah me too no
it's not making 30 times more Austin
it's doing what a plant might help
purify the air it's not meant to in in
terms of like that's its main purpose
but it by byproduct it's also kind of
purifying the air this is just probably
saying that it's doing it 30 times more
than regular Plants they say that the
air in your home is up to five times
more polluted than outdoor air due to
volatile organic compounds or vocs and
these are just carcinogens molecules
right
um emitted by solving solvents and
varnishes using most Furnishings
textiles cleaning and personal they're
giving us a problem that we don't give a
[__] yeah tell me that you're making us
care about it they're creating the
problem and then the solution the same
thing exactly and they're saying it's 30
times better than top NASA plants so
they really cracked the code what NASA
plan I know NASA had plants I didn't
know everybody at Nashville's 150 years
old so regular Plants tested by NASA
sometimes capture these vocs but in but
without a way to recycle them into
useful elements oh we need to recycle
them yeah oh so instead of storing the
pollutants you've got to use plant
technology this thing can can turn them
to turn the pollutants into water sugars
amino acids and oxygen which makes it a
more powerful plant and an elegant way
to purify the air and they have a graph
about how this lowers their VOC
concentrations per hour versus average
house plants whoa It's Going Down yeah I
mean when there's graphs now I believe
the green one is them the other ones if
there's like an air purifier the air
purifier is going like this pull out the
grass hey buy the dip how much how much
[__] how much 55 you guys Max
remember 30 bucks I spent 30 bucks you
don't remember basic science in
elementary school when they taught you
that when you talk to your plants it
helps them grow and then they go but
actually it's because your CO2 you know
because when you yeah that's why they
grow I've been wasting a lot of nice
words on my plans but they said talk to
them they said talk to your plants
that's science that you learn in
elementary no but there's that whole
emotional like rice Thing by the
Japanese dude right that's water all
right I basically give I give up on the
price thing I'm just going to tell you
it's 179 70 179 not doing it dude buy a
purified we didn't we don't need it
stupid just buy more plants would you
pay 170 no hey I was close get a [__]
palm tree for that 200 Euros that's
pretty close got a couple of Ficus I
would pay 179 after 50 years of case
study and everyone's [__] 2 000 years
old because this plant of course you
take that long and [__] that math
doesn't add up by the way yeah after 50
years everyone's 2 000.
yeah but what if that plant gets
released into the wild and then now we
all get oxygen poison because it like
it's invasive and we don't have we're
not supposed to have that much oxygen
coming out of plant well then you better
talk to all those plants yeah dude you
better figure that out you better set
that off that means I'm gonna grow it
more just send Bart out there with his
[__] stupid what did he do with in
the communities oh yeah we used to just
[__] yeah send these two guys out
there yeah who's Anthony out there to
chop up all the plants invasive species
179 bucks not anymore